going back to this idea of
multiculturalism i think there's that
it's almost like politicians they have a
greater emphasis on what's different
about us and they celebrate that but
they don't understand the complications
that come with diversity because
ultimately if you have if there's a
great deal of cultural diversity
but you have that lack of that's that's
sort of that unifying um set of values
then you kind of
you almost have a balconization process
and i think that's that's quite
problematic because if that if there's a
lack of social trust in a diverse
society such as ours you almost lose
public support for ambitious
collectivist sort of endeavors such as
the all-encompassing welfare state
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
political writer and the author of an
upcoming book called manufactured
grievance which we're both really
looking forward to reading dr hibas and
welcome to trigonometry thank you for
having me uh it's a pleasure to have you
on been meaning to have you on for a
while uh for anyone who doesn't know who
you are and we've been reading all your
stuff and it's absolutely fascinating
tell everybody who are you how are you
where you are what is it that brings you
to be uh sitting here talking to us so
as you say i'm a political writer i'm
the author of the upcoming book
manufactured grievance
in terms of my life i was born in
hammersmith but i moved to luton at the
age of one so i've lived there for the
past three decades and i'm particularly
interested in social cohesion how to
strengthen relations between the state
and citizens and just generally how do
we create a more cohesive country and
how do we enhance democratic stability
in britain
and you've written a lot about race
relations and the commentary that we've
now seen about race and there seems to
be this interesting dynamic that's
happened certainly in my lifetime in
this country which is kind of similar to
your 20 25 years whatever uh 30 years
where like
the the society seems to be making
progress on the issues of race and yet
the conversation seems to be the
opposite like things are getting worse
all the time what have you made of the
last kind of period of time during which
we've seen that happen well i think in
terms of britain i almost feel that
there's been an importation
of u.s racial politics and i think you
see things like a blm demonstration in
london where people are chanting don't
shoot
british police officers even though the
vast majority are unarmed and they
support that model of policing and i do
think there has been that brainless
importation of racial grievance politics
in the united states and that's being
imported by the british identitarian
left i think in recent times we have
seen an explosion of racial grievance
politics i talk about the
uh industrial uh complex the grievance
industrial complex where you have a
sector-wide orchestrated effort to
present britain in a way that i simply
don't recognize
and you say you simply don't recognize
it and you grew up in luton which was
you know
from what i've read seems to be a hotbed
of racial tension at certain points in
the 90s well i think lindsay's fair
share of problems
i think is the birthplace of the english
defense lawyer so tommy robinson for our
american viewers that's where all that
absolutely yeah and it's also had its
fair share of issues with islamist
extremism tensions not just between
the white population and the non-white
population but also tensions between
different ethnic minorities something
that's not really discussed too much
when we talk about race relations in
britain
but also with luton you have that
tolerant majority uh people who are
ultimately more interested in who you
are as a person what your attitudes are
what you what you bring to the table as
a as a character and i think that's
generally the argument i make about
england i think you do have these hard
left identitarians who really see the
worst in england then you have hard
right ethnonationalists who ultimately
frame english identity in terms of race
and ancestry
but in reality you have the mainstream
when they're asked about englishness
what englishness means to them they
focus
they ultimately frame it in more civic
terms it's about your social
contribution how do you contribute
towards the well-being of your local
community
things such as paying taxes towards the
funding of public services and national
security so you can see that there is
definitely a potential for a civic
englishness and i think these sort of
these grossly simplistic caricatures of
england are very unfair
and you say they're very unfair and it
was very interesting in 2020 when we saw
that explosion of race-based politics
the discussions the anger the
recriminations do you think that's gone
away or do you or do you think it's
still bubbling under the sun i think
it's definitely there i think it's still
there i think the issue is that for too
long i think when we're looking at
england in particular
people have just thought that or you
know english we don't really want to
touch it as a concept perhaps because
they felt there's this cultural
appropriation of the saint george's flag
for example by far-right organizations
such as the english defense league
but you know the reality of the matter
is if you don't talk about those kind of
things as a vacuum and radical
ideologues will exploit that i think in
terms of when we're looking more
recently when you look at the labour
party
more broadly the contemporary british
left i think that there's been a
tendency to portray britain in a way
that even people who consider themselves
to be anti-racist it's alienating i
don't think they see
britain more generally as a kind of
society where this is
full to the brim with reactionary
throwbacks people who are deeply
uncomfortable with demographic diversity
they might be uncomfortable with
cultural diversity which is obviously
very different to demographic diversity
and they may feel that there are certain
practices in britain
which are very much against liberal
democratic values i don't think that's
controversial at all can you delve into
that a little bit more the cultural
diversity versus demographic diversity
and what you're talking about uh what
you're hinting out there because it's
good i think that there's an interesting
piece in there but you're being a little
bit vague about it so give us some more
space
i'll definitely i'll flesh out in more
detail so i think in terms of
demographic diversity when we're looking
at the degree to which britain is
religiously diverse racially diverse and
ethnically diverse that's very different
to cultural diversity now if you see
that when we look at brexit for example
one of the strongest predictors for
someone voting to leave the european
union was if they had a negative view of
cultural diversity now that doesn't mean
that they're fed up with all the brown
and black faces in the united kingdom it
might be the fact that they feel that
there's a lack of discussion on shared
values they may they may feel that
there's cultural practices which are not
in keeping with what they consider to be
traditional british liberal democratic
principles they may feel that um
principles such as democratic choice the
rule of law these kind of things are
being eroded as a result of
certain cultural practices
so you can see that there's a there's a
big difference between being
uncomfortable with demographic diversity
which i think the majority of british
people aren't but they may have
reservations over the degree to which we
celebrate difference and how little we
discuss
um things such as shared values
articulating and inclusive patriotism or
just more generally
generating a feeling or a sense of
common purpose
that's a really interesting point isn't
it because i i do feel that that's been
happening if you i don't know if it's
happening in wider society particularly
if you go outside of the big cities i do
think there's a very strong sense of
social cohesion but if you were to watch
let's say the bbc or other mainstream
media the hyper focus on
uh the things that we're all different
in seems to be
extreme it seems to be that that is the
only thing anyone's talking about and
almost there was a period of time
particularly i think around brexit when
the idea of british values was which is
what you're really talking about was
it's almost like if you talk to someone
you say well what are british values
they'd run away as if you're trying to
recruit them for the edl you know what i
mean yeah no i think so and i think that
we need to have these kind of
discussions because i think with the
ethnically racially and religiously
diverse society you need to have that
common moral cultural standard to tie
those different groups together and i
think that in recent times i don't i
think there's been an absence of moral
political leadership on those kind of
issues
but do do you sometimes think looking
back at that out that outburst in 2020.
that
okay what the protesters didn't have
they weren't right about the issue but
that anger has to have come from
somewhere it couldn't have just come
from nothing if that protest hadn't
struck a chord in some way would it have
existed do you see what i'm getting at
here there must be something else that
people feel angry or frustrated about
yeah i mean i think that in certain
ethnic minorities there is a high level
of political disaffection i think that's
particularly the case with uh
british-born people of caribbean
origin and i think for example the
racist murder of stephen lawrence and
then the spying of his family by the
london metropolitan police undercover
spying
that thing that that kind of thing it
leaves uh it it costs a long shadow and
i think we have to really look at how
for example we can improve relations
between disaffected communities and
local police forces uh what were the
kind of things that can be done to
boost public support for robust policing
practices such as stop and search i
think more generally
i always thought that the traditional
english promise of equality of
opportunity i think there's more to be
done i think that there is plenty more
that can be done in terms of creating a
more meritocratic society a society
where opportunities and rewards are
allocated on the basis of merit
so i think there's definitely
discussions to be had and what are some
of the challenges in the era because i
would imagine one of them that i uh have
read about and i'm i do believe is an
issue is for example your name is ricky
bessan if your name was john smith you'd
probably have an easier time applying
for jobs by sending in the cv we have
seen evidence of is that the sort of
thing you're talking about but i think
also if you're someone of character if
you're black caribbean origin and your
name is john powell i think you may be
at an advantage if you're as opposed to
your name was constantine kissing yeah
so it's not quite as simple as being a
racial penalty as such because it's more
of a cultural penalty because
constantine kissing is more culturally
distant you could say to a traditionally
english-sounding name he keeps telling
me that yeah
and i'm right so i think those kind of
discussions where you talk about maybe
introducing more name-blind applications
at least that may be my that might be
more of an equalizer in terms of the
equalization of opportunity and i think
that's quite important it's not so much
about an equality of outcomes it's more
about trying to create a more fairer
process
especially in the realm of employment
which as you know ultimately you know
employment is the it's almost the core
of one's life
essentially it gives you a sense of
structure a sense of pride
also helps to put food on the table as
well and pay the bills so i think those
kind of discussions are really important
i don't think i think we should guard
against complacency
while i say that you know overall we're
a tolerant
anti-discrimination pro-equality country
that's not to say that we can improve on
those fronts but what i don't agree with
is ultimately a vilification of british
society and his public institutions and
i do think the
more aggressive elements of the blm
movement they have been responsible for
doing that and that in turn undermines
the broader anti-racism cause because it
alienates people who do care about
racial equality but they don't share
that warped interpretation of british
society and institutions in both the
public and private sector and why do you
think these people have been given a
platform like you see the same faces
rolled out again and again and again
some of your favorites yeah yeah
absolutely
but why is it we consistently give these
people a platform if as you say
their their view of british society is
warped well i think in certain public
institutions uh mainstream public
broadcasters such as the bbc
i do sense there's a great deal of white
guilt in those institutions if i'm being
perfectly honest and as as you've said
you see these same voices and they
recycle their identitarian nonsense
which is deeply divisive and i think all
too often ethnic minority voices i think
that there's improvements being made on
that front but ethnic minority voices
who might provide a more optimistic
positive vision
of britain and rather providing a
positive interpretation of race
relations how we're doing in um when it
comes to matters of racial equality i
think for a while they were being
sidelined if i'm being perfectly honest
but obviously you have gb news you have
people there such as mercy meraki
aminaya following oman who at least
provide a more balanced perspective and
i think that's really important because
you don't want uh
identitarian leftists seizing the
narrative when it comes to race-related
issues in britain
and your book is called manufactured
grievance i want to talk about the
grievance industry a little bit because
you're wondering how to get into it
absolutely man i'm determined it's very
profitable so jews kind of struggle in
that for some reason but anyway um i i'm
just curious a lot of people may not be
familiar with this idea or they might
find it inherently difficult to accept
but it seems quite obvious to me at this
point and tell me if you agree with this
that there are a lot of people and i
don't even blame them because human
beings respond to incentives right if
you can get a good job and with a great
salary and social status and newspaper
inches and and whatever by having a
particular mindset you will attract
people to to to doing that absolutely
yeah and so it does seem to me like
there are a lot of people who just
don't want things to get better
no
but in the show no they don't and i
think that when i talk about the
grievance industrial complex i'll give
you an example the runnymede trust back
in 2000 they set up a 23 strong
commission to look at the issue racial
equality issues in britain and they
concluded that britain had some of the
best race relations uh in europe it said
that it had a much more relaxed society
than other
multi-ethnic democracies such as france
germany and the united states and they
said that the idea that racism was
widespread in britain was a skewed and
partisan view
now
the running me trust now this year
published a report which said that
england suffers from systemic racism
uh that ultimately limits the enjoyment
of being rights and acronym that i think
is absolutely hopeless by the way maybe
we can discuss that later on and
ultimately portraying england as some
sort kind of systemically racist hell
hole so you can see that the same
institution from the year 2000
to now is essentially saying that
our country has descended from being an
internationally reputable model for race
relations to systemically racist
hellhole now that's a scorching hot take
that i don't think many people would
share at all and i do feel that
institutions perhaps because they see
that there's an opportunity for
financial profit
combined with this moral grandstanding
so ultimately it's impressing people in
their particular sector in their social
circles
and you also have that financial
incentive
to present what i would consider to be a
fundamentally warped interpretation
of race relations in the uk and how well
we're doing in terms of racial equality
but crucially when it comes to complex
uh forms of social and economic
disadvantage all too often they'll put
racial identity at the heart of it when
i think there's other very important
factors in place such as internal
cultural norms in particular communities
um attitudes towards female empowerment
uh also even things such as where you
live i think geographical inequality we
live in one of the most inter-regionally
imbalanced
economies in the world
i think family breakdown is something
that many people simply don't want to
touch with a barge pole i think the
great advantage you could have in modern
day britain is if you are raised by
two loving attentive parents now that's
not and but then people portray that
some kind of vilification of single
parents not at all but i don't think we
should shy away from the fact that
there's particular family structures
which are more strongly associated with
positive youth outcomes whether it's
school attainment cognitive development
mental well-being um being less likely
to be involved in the criminal justice
system i think those are the discussions
we need to be having when it comes to
matters of inequality in britain why
don't we have those discussions well i
think a lot of people that they just
like being politically sensitive i think
as opposed to grappling with the main
issues
um
they want to be liked i think that's
what it is and i don't really care for
being overly popular of being well liked
because i think if you want to be a a
serious actor that wants to tackle the
root causes of inequality
then you're going to have to face up to
some uncomfortable truths now for me
britain i think there's many wonderful
things about britain britain is also an
international hot spot when it comes to
family breakdown and as i've discussed i
think family structure can be hugely
influential when it comes to youth
development and future life progression
and i think that needs to be better
reflected in british social policy
because i think all too often we
we're guided more by what's fashionable
as opposed to the facts and i think
that's hugely problematic in the social
policy space
hey constantin how are you feeling
good and your mental health i'm from
russia we don't have mental health well
in the civilized world we talk about our
mental health and how we're feeling
about our place in the universe in the
words of my uncle vlad that is why we
will crush you well he's two months away
from a breakdown for the rest of us
there's a number one mental wellness app
called calm that helps you to negotiate
the tricky modern world it's okay to
need help sometimes and calm can provide
support calm has been really useful for
me you can clear your head with guided
daily meditations improve your focus
with calm's curated music tracks and
drift off to dreamland with calm's
imaginative sleep stories narrated by
soothing voices like killian murphy and
stephen fry oh killian save me man up
drink vodka feel better if you go to
calm.com trigger you'll get a limited
time offer of 40 off a calm premium
subscription which includes hundreds of
hours of programming and new content is
added every week over 1 million people
around the world use calm to take care
of their minds yes trigonometry fans get
special limited time promotion 40 off
premium subscription take advantage of
this amazing offer go to com.com forward
slash trigger for 40 percent of
unlimited access to calm entire library
that's calm dot com forward slash
trigger
do you think there's
there's another thing here which is
we've bought into some kind of to me and
i consider myself liberal but we've
bought into a form of liberalism that
that almost says
nothing is right nothing is wrong
nothing is good nothing is bad it's just
hey man just do whatever you want and so
if you are
in a single parent environment
nobody should should ever say anything
about what that can lead to on average
right you're not talking about
individual people you're saying on
average a kid with two parents does
better on average than a kid with one
parent right yeah it's not criticism of
single parents but it's just saying this
is the reality yeah what works best to
say what works best right just in terms
of practical outcomes but but to say
that is to judge and we don't want to
judge anything anymore well for me it's
not making some kind of emotional
judgment i'm looking at what the
evidence is telling me right and i think
that's something where the left and
unfortunately it's guided more by
emotions
and political correctness as opposed to
actually acknowledging what the facts
were the realities on the ground now
when we talk about disparities for
example one of the things that isn't
talked about very much at all is that is
the huge differences between different
ethnic groups when it comes to the kind
of family structure that young people
are raised in so when it comes to people
aged up to
15 years
whether or not they live in a lone
parent household so the figure for
dependence of indian origin is only six
percent that rises to 63 for children of
black caribbean origin and i think that
kind of difference is bound to have an
impact on the kind of live trajectory
for young people in those particular
ethnic groups now blm of course there's
some there's many discussions to be had
in terms of racial discrimination ethnic
penalties in the labor market how we can
create a health care system which is
more responsive to the needs of a
diverse population but one of the
biggest problems facing many black
british communities
is the lack of responsible male role
models in those communities and i think
when it comes to issues of
fatherlessness that's something that for
example dr tony sewell who is the lead
author of the recent
cred report and interestingly david
lammer used to talk about this a great
deal um
you know in my early years of adulthood
he was my favorite politician because
what he did he managed to blend this
strong commitment to social justice with
a with almost like an honest
family-oriented traditionalism and i
feel that perhaps because he had some
personal disappointments such as
finishing forth in the labour candidacy
for the um uh mayoral mayoral election
in 2016 which city khan obviously when
he finished fourth he finished behind
diane abbott so that would be a better
pill to swallow especially for a man of
his intellect
but it's a real shame that he turned his
back on that politics perhaps because he
realized within the labour party that
sort of tribal racial identity politics
radical social liberal liberalism was
very much um
very much on the up so perhaps that led
to a disintegration or rather his
abandonment of his own humanitarian
politics and i think that's a real shame
it is a real shame because like you said
he's he's a very very intelligent man
and he could be a powerful force within
the labour party there's an article of
yours i
found very very interesting talking
about muslims in the uk and how actually
the uk is
probably the best place in the eu to
live for muslims could you go into a
little bit about that well i think it
was interesting that you had the
european court of justice they recently
um ruled that
muslim european muslim women who wore
hijab in the workplace if the um if
their employers think that that is
leading to workplace conflicts or that's
affecting
kind of you know relations with clients
and customers that they could be fired
now that's something that would never
happen in the united kingdom and you saw
that after brexit you had these kind of
intolerant britain versus tolerant
europe narratives from a band of
deranged eu enthusiasts that's the way i
described them
when in reality britain when it comes
for example the provision of
anti-discrimination protections on the
grounds of race
religion ethnicity britain comfortably
outperforms countries such as france
france has this sort of almost rigid
secular universalism
the idea that they'd even collect data
broken down by race and ethnicity
completely goes against
that that kind of political culture that
they have in place that's obviously
problematic because you can't identify
issues of racial discrimination in
various fields in britain we have a
strong commitment to collecting that
kind of data and then at least
discussing you know how we go about
approaching those kind of issues uh
other countries such as germany and
netherlands i wouldn't say their
provision of those anti-discrimination
protections are as robust as in the case
of the uk
and i think that when it comes to
british muslims in particular
i feel that they're poorly represented
by identitarian organizations who quite
frankly they tap into that religious
grievance politics i would say so three
and four british muslims feel that
britain is a good place to live as a
muslim and the main reason they provide
for that is freedom of religion what's
interesting is that it's the mainstream
who are less likely to think that
britain is a good place to live as a
muslim i don't know whether there's some
kind of white savior complex um at play
there very possible but i do feel that
you know personally as a british muslim
myself i do think that britain is a very
good place to live as
you know as you know in terms of you
know practicing your religion uh it's
also worth noting that
many muslim people who live in britain
they originate from countries which are
deeply unstable in a social sense
there's rampant institutional corruption
uh there's a great deal of you know
community tensions also between
different muslim denominations islamic
denominations so that when you compare
that context that that you know that
kind of social disturbance and those
political problems there naturally that
they have a positive orientation they
have a positive
feeling towards british democracy but
all too often these kind of things are
not discussed about at all when we talk
about the place of british muslims in
their own country well rakib speaking of
that and it'd be interesting to talk
about this you being a practicing muslim
because one of the things that people
sometimes and admittedly these are
people who are on the sort of hard right
but this is one of the things that they
often talk about that
british muslims struggle to integrate
and they'll point at things like
the polls which show british attitude
muslim attitudes to homosexuality to
women's liberation and all this sort of
stuff where do you sit on all of that
like how well is is the muslim community
if one exists integrating and has
integrated into british well i think
that that's the thing there that all too
often is presented a british muslim
community yeah it's so incredibly
diverse in terms of social values and
political affiliation
more generally when it comes to issues
of female empowerment
uh and just generally what is the place
of british muslims in their own country
that there is a great deal of diversity
also just things with ethnicity and
different religious denominations as
well i i think that there's definitely
discussion to be had in terms of you
know where is the place of british
muslim women for example
um because i do feel that for example
when you look at levels of child poverty
in certain muslim majority communities i
think female empowerment needs to be
discussed because i think that when we
see
various cases across the world that is
the most effective route out of poverty
for certain groups and societies
empowering women and i think those
discussions need to be had in britain i
think in terms of
how british muslims are caricatured i
think that on the hard left you have you
know these people are deeply oppressed
they're really struggling in a in a
aggressively anti-muslim country which
has no respect for them
doesn't you know the mainstream doesn't
like them whatsoever and then you have
the hard right ethno nationalists who
portray british muslims of some kind of
you know
almost like a fifth columnist block
of disloyal
uh people
who who live in britain but in reality
that they both can be further from the
truth as i said the vast majority of
british muslims they're satisfied with
british democracy they think that
britain is a good place to live as a
muslim uh
generally high level relatively high
levels of trust in public institutions
such as the nhs
and they also show high levels of
british identification which many people
are quite surprised about especially
british pakistanis and british
bangladeshis they do show high levels of
british identification so you can see
there that all too often you do have
radical ideologues who dominate the
conversation
when
they they're not you know the arguments
that they provide they're not rooted in
reality at all and it's interesting you
say that because you made the point
about muslim people on a monolith and of
course it's so true like i've got
friends who are who are muslim and one
of them is indonesia now obviously an
indonesian muslim is going to be very
very different to a bangladeshi muslim
because their countries are completely
different their societies are different
do we need to start realizing that you
know when we talk about things like
asian people black people these terms
are really reductive and pointless and
they don't actually
describe people accurately well i think
you'd even get differences between the
every average muslim from dhaka which is
the capital of bangladesh and silla
which is uh um you know dark is a bit
more modernized a bit more developed a
bit more socially liberal you could say
while silence is more socially
conservative
bit poorer more deprived more
agricultural so you can even see within
one muslim country you can see that the
the regional difference is there so i
think we really need to have a
discussion about
you know to what extent are people
homogenizing very different groups so
after the credit report came out the
serial report i think even labels such
as black and asian they're they're you
know they're bringing together vastly
different groups
uh there's huge differences in kind of
sort of socio-economic integration
political behavior between british
indians and british pakistanis but
they'd both be brought into a asian
category there's there's also very
serious differences between people of
black caribbean origin and people of
black african origin you can see that
even in terms of pupil performance in
english schools perception of race
relations to what extent do they attach
importance to their faith
um their general perception of british
society and public institutions so i
think even those kind of labels those
sort of overarching racial categories
they're not particularly useful from a
social policy perspective at all
ricky one of the things i was wondering
about in terms of having these
conversations and why sometimes we as a
society seem reluctant to do is there
was a moment and i think that moment is
in the past now but there was a moment
where multiculturalism was the thing
right that was the word and everybody
had to get by into this idea what do you
make of
multiculturalism and the attempt to kind
of mainstream that as a thing you're
smiling i think the state-sponsored
multiculturalism is a disastrous model
for you know sort of political and
social integration i think the explain
that for people who who may not like
because some people don't even
understand the difference between a
multi-ethnic society and a multicultural
society so give us the definitions and
then tell us why i think a multi-ethnic
society can have a strong inclusive
patriotism which ultimately focuses more
on shared values or rather you have a
you almost say you have a
socio-political effort to cultivate
uh you know a sense of common purpose
uh
it's essentially trying to bring
together different groups in society
are almost around this common
moral cultural standard under one
umbrella identity so i'm from russia
francis's mixed background you are
wherever you are you're practicing
muslim but we're all british yeah right
we all buy into the british identity
exactly that's a multi-ethnic society
yeah and i think that just needs to be
at least you have discussions about what
is that what is it the core of that
civic identity so i'll talk about things
like social contribution
ultimately treating people fairly
irrespective of their ethnic racial
religious background and also having a
discussion about what kind of cultural
practices
shouldn't have any place in british
society and i think that that kind of
those kind of discussions still what you
can tell you keep saying this thing but
you never spell it well i think even
things like um if i had to talk about
fgm female genital mutilation i think
that the inaction on those kind of
issues for so long
was it was embarrassing to be honest i
think that's a national scandal in in
itself so i think those kind of things
that all for
far too long we've had political leaders
they want to avoid those kind of topics
but they really care about you know sort
of you know the women's rights for
example i think that's very interesting
you have the progressive left they talk
about you know how they want to
protect women's rights how they want to
strengthen them but when it comes to
those kind of sensitive issues because
they might be more prevalent in minority
communities
all too often they don't really want to
talk about it they're deeply
uncomfortable
and it's almost like their political
correctness gets in the way
of taking action on those kind of issues
but i think in going back to this idea
of multiculturalism i think there's that
it's almost like politicians they have a
greater emphasis on what's different
about us and they celebrate that but
they don't understand the complications
that come with diversity because
ultimately if you have a if there's a
great deal of cultural diversity
but you have that lack of that's that's
sort of that unifying um set of values
then you kind of
you almost have a balconization process
and i think that's that's quite
problematic because if that if there's a
lack of social trust in a diverse
society such as ours you almost lose
public support for ambitious
collectivist sort of endeavors such as
the all-encompassing welfare state now i
traditionally identify with the left i
do think that we should have an
all-encompassing welfare state but in
order to sustain that and keep that in
healthy condition
you need to have high levels of social
solidarity
and i think that that's that's where my
sort of traditional leftism that's what
it's rooted in that sense that you need
to have a stable national membership you
need to have high levels of social trust
and i think that actually leads to
immigration for example i do think that
you need to have a fairly restrictive
immigration system in order to sustain
that welfare state because i think that
if you if you have this kind of it's a
constant flux
in a sense it trust takes a long time to
develop especially when it comes you
know it's between different racial
ethnic and religious groups so i really
think that we need to have i think on
the left the left needs to have more
discussions about immigration i think
that all too often we've had these um
open border cosmopolitans who have
almost dominated the debate um on the
left and i think that's actually
alienating for many traditional
working-class voters who may
associate well traditionally associated
themselves with labour but now maybe
looking elsewhere to offer their
electoral support so i think ultimately
with multiculturalism it's about trying
to create a unifying set of values and
almost you're being guarded against that
celebration of difference because i
think if you go over the top with that
it makes it very difficult to create a
cohesive hole
you've made a lot of good points you
talked about being on the left and yet
wanting a policy of immigration that is
restrictive
i mean you can't say that if you're on
the left most people
i mean
what are you gonna do in your face what
are you gonna do
but most people on the left can't do
that because it seems to me a lot of
leaders on the left are crippled by two
emotions guilt and fear
i think that for example when it came to
freedom i think that was one of the
reasons why we voted out to be honest i
think that people say oh you know this
was driven by anti-immigrant sentiment
well
also i'd make the point that there's
decent levels of brexit supporting
ethnic minority communities especially
particularly well-off indian origin
communities in west london
i come from luton which invited 56.5
leave now that wasn't purely white
working-class people fighting to leave
the european union they had decent
levels of leave support across different
ethnic and religious groups i think that
there is that acknowledgement in many
communities that if you want to have a
sustainable welfare state you need to
have high levels of social trust and
social solidarity so ultimately it's
almost a sense that if you want to
support if you're supportive of that
kind of welfare state that's not
compatible with an open borders policy
and i think that's what many people on
the left really struggle to understand
but i think many british people get but
that's perhaps why labour
you know they're not very good at
winning elections nowadays do you think
they struggle to understand it or do you
think they're just scared in order
because if they do come out and talk
about restrictive immigration they'll be
demonized as racist whatever else
particularly and they're more likely to
be demonized as racist if they're white
i mean look at sorry
but just look at like kia stammer when
he first became leader he tried to talk
about the flag and then you know
whatever yeah and he got creamed for
that so what are they what are they
going to tear off him if he starts
talking about immigration do you know
what i mean i think his problem is
he's not very convincing when he
expresses his
supposedly patriotic feelings
i don't think it's very it's not
authentic i think there's an
authenticity problem there i think that
being the chief architect of the second
referendum policy i think that that
really undermined his own reputation in
pro-brexit working-class communities who
traditionally voted for the labour party
i think that when you look at those
discussions i think there is there is an
intellectual deficit on the left if i'm
being completely honest but i also agree
that even if people may feel that way
perhaps they don't feel comfortable in
articulating that those kind of views
because of the ideological leanings of
their own social circles that's a
possibility
and doesn't that just mean okay because
i see myself on the left as well even
though a lot of them probably would hate
to have me on the left yeah i'm sure
they would
you didn't have to say that but anyway
but don't you think that effectively
what we're going to see now is a
conservative government that's just
going to reign for generations i think
that's poor for british democracy i
think you need to have a robust in you
need robust intellectual opposition to
keep the government in check i think you
almost have that kind of sclerosis you
know the
thing mistakes um
at the heart of government
behaviors which i i don't particularly
support at the heart of government as
well matt hancock springs to mind but i
think those kind of things creep in when
there's a weak opposition yeah from
being perfectly honest and even with all
those things going on the tories
continue to register leads in every poll
i think professor matt goodwin i think i
think is nearly 131 consecutive polls
now that the tories have been ahead of
labour labour have been out of power for
11 years yeah and i wouldn't say that
the government is a particularly
a high performing government i think i
think
i think overall i think the main issue
is that it's not so much that people are
really supportive of the government they
love the conservative party he said they
just they dread the alternative
that's so true ricky let me ask you the
devil's advocate question uh which is
aren't all you know i never pretended to
be on the left i've always thought of
myself in the center but the two of you
are aren't you just two conservatives
who are really deep down you just hate
immigrants and you're just sitting here
going well i used to be on the left but
actually get them out do you know what i
mean
it's like it's unusual to be accused of
that being a bangladesh in india origin
but i think that ultimately you need but
there are people who would do that
they'd say you're a coconut well
actually i mean i've heard it all before
uncle tom coconut race traitor house
muslim and all the rest of us all wore
off the ducks back for me i couldn't
care less because ultimately i know that
what i'm saying is quite well it's
relevant i think it's necessary
and i think when you look at you know
myself and francis identify with the
left one of the first things i did when
i obtained full-time employment was join
a trade union
which i think is a fairly leftist thing
to do
i think that as i said i support an
all-encompassing welfare state i care a
lot about the nhs in terms of being
responsive to the needs of a diverse
population
um
i also want to see a fairly active state
in in terms of trying to
develop public infrastructure in some of
the poorest parts of the country i think
these are quite classic bread and butter
leftist
issues
it's just that when it comes to these
the sort of racial grievance politics
the reality is that the traditional
british left is rooted in social
solidarity so i see that racial
grievance politics as a betrayal of
traditional labour politics and i don't
think that's a particularly
controversial view to offer
and do you think
your
argument is going to win because the
worry i have with the racial grievance
stuff
and they found a way because they tried
it with feminism and it didn't quite
work because at the end of the day you
can't really separate women and men
enough like to see them for them to see
each other as enemies but with racial
groups we are hardwired for tribalism
and i just worry that this ideology is
so
like
it's right there in the gut do you know
what i mean and it preys on your worst
instincts exactly and if you teach
people that over time i just feel like
it's going to be hard for your very
reasonable point of view to triumph over
that thing that hits you right in here
do you know what i mean i don't think my
arguments will win on the left i'd like
to see it win on the left if i'm being
perfectly honest i think that's a big
part of my book manufactured grievance i
want to offer the left away out in terms
of being a more mature and inclusive
force in british political society
i'm not sure if that will happen but i
think my arguments will win
my kind of arguments would win out in
the mainstream and i think that's
important and i already said that i
think the mainstream is more tolerant
than many people on the left portray
them to be i think that they are quite
concerned
well they're concerned about rooting out
discrimination wherever you find it
whatever kind of discrimination that is
but in terms of would my arguments win
on the left i'm not particularly sure
but i do see i see people for example
paul embry the kind of arguments he
makes i think they're very important
and i do feel that kind of blue labor
tendency those kind of writers um adrian
pabst would be another one i think they
they bring important discussions to the
top they bring important points to the
table but if you're talking about i
almost feel that there's a there's a
battle for the left soul
in a sense i'm not sure how that will
pan out
uh but i think when you're talking about
my kind of arguments i think ultimately
it's about you know
whether or not or i win here or i win
there i think it's ultimately portraying
you know what what i think about britain
what i think would be a positive way
forwards when it comes to race relations
and community cohesion and then i'll let
people discuss about it
hey francis do you want to learn another
language no mate i'm english if
foreigners can't understand me i just
shout at them think about it you could
learn how to say penalties in italian
leave it but if you do want to learn
another language because maybe you want
to have new experiences live in another
country or maybe you just want to open
your mind my mind's open enough if i
open it up any further my brain's going
to hurt this is true but babel's
15-minute lessons make it the perfect
way to learn a new language on the go
they design their courses with practical
real-world conversations in mind
sentences you'll use in normal everyday
life sentences like oi pedro dos
services
thank you francis and bible's courses
have been proven to be scientific
and bible's courses have been proven to
be scientifically effective across
multiple studies their 15-minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go it's available as an
app or online and your progress will be
synced across all devices you can choose
from 14 different languages including
spanish french italian and german
they've also got their own podcast so
you can brush up on your french and
spanish on the go start your new
language learning journey today with
babel and before you know it
hablar espanol absolutamente perfecto
now i mean gary right now babel is
offering our listeners six months free
with a purchase of a six-month
subscription with our promo code which
is of course trigger go to uk dot babble
dot com slash play and use promo code
trigger for an extra six months free
that's uk
dot b a b b e l dot c o m forward slash
play
promo code trigger
[Music]
there's something that i really wanted
to discuss with you and you brought it
up there about
the let's call them what they are the
racial slurs that have been held against
you by people on the left sure number
one why does that happen and number two
why do people not think that is racist
because if it came from the mouth of you
know a white van driver whatever else to
use a cultural stereotype you'd be like
well that's racism and you'd be right
but why is it acceptable just because
someone's got pronouns in their bio to
do it to you and
that's fine because they think they're
moral guardians
they see themselves as moral guardians
so they can't even understand you know
how what they're doing is wrong they
don't believe it and when you try to
explain it to them they still they still
don't really see what they're doing
wrong at all
um i think that when it comes to those
kind of racial slurs i think you almost
see that kind of i think for example
with blm i think there's been an
increase in intra black animosity black
people who don't who refuse to tote the
identitarian line
it's almost like their their black
authenticity is being questioned and i
think you have you i think you also have
that similar kind of dynamic in asian
communities muslim communities if you
have a particular issue on
counter-terrorism for example
counter-extremism uh social integration
and discrimination more generally you'll
have you know one muslim might accuse
another muslim of being a sort of house
muslim almost trying to appease
non-muslim people so you have that kind
it's really nasty
kind of the kind of tensions which have
developed in recent times and i do think
there's been a normalization of
left-wing bigotry which is going to
alienate not just much of the sort of
white british mainstream but i think
many traditional minded ethnic minority
people find it hugely problematic
it's interesting and you bring up the
the tensions within uh again i use i
hate the word community because i think
it's just been abused to to death now
but within the the muslim population in
the uk particularly in relation to
counter terrorism and and all of that
sort of thing
i mean a question that i think a lot of
people
don't ask out loud but but my ask inside
the privacy of their own home or inside
of their head is
why do have we had and thank god it
hasn't happened in the last year or two
but why do we have you know over the
last 10 15 years terrorist attacks on
the streets of london that are almost
inevitably always committed by someone
who's a muslim why is that happening i
think that there's real issues in terms
of social integration i think that we
have allowed counter societies to
develop in particular parts of the
country
and perhaps maybe because of political
correctness or rather just the naivety
that people who originate from fairly
unstable countries they'll just enjoy
the freedoms that are offered within
british democracy i think there has been
it's almost like a misplaced idealism in
in a way
i i think that people talk about you
know foreign policy the invasion of iraq
um
the war in afghanistan
but i do think that we
it's almost a bit that us and their
mentality has been allowed to fester
in particular communities
and i think that in a way that you've
had this sort of model of
multiculturalism which has almost
empowered these self self-appointed
community leaders who aren't necessarily
help from from a social cohesion
perspective by the way that they've been
empowered while you've had the more
sort of patriotic reformist kind of
forces in british muslim communities
they've almost had the legs cut off
under them really they've just been left
behind abandoned and i think that that's
been a real problem when we're talking
about you know the threat of islamist
extremism i think that those kind of
dynamics have been
they just haven't been productive at all
in terms of trying to create a more
cohesive society
and i do feel that
in terms of those discussions about the
place of british muslims i think that
the
the wrong organizations at times have
been empowered in terms of you know
being platformed being offered offered a
view
when okay you can offer them a view but
then just to completely alienate people
who might have a different point of view
or rather not even give them to the
opportunity to articulate that their
more positive optimistic view of britain
i think that's been hugely you know
hugely troubling to see and do you think
part of the problem is that in the media
and just in general negative messages
are in some ways far more powerful than
positive messages i think so i think
that my kind of views maybe perhaps it
doesn't you know attract much on you
know social media
social media engagement i think that the
media ultimately it functions on hits
attention and i think i guess maybe
outlandish outrageous almost extremist
views
it gathers people's attention well i
think that more sort of moderate
optimistic positive views
perhaps you know
certain editors certain channels they're
just reluctant to
platform those views because they don't
see it generating much attention to
their outlets so what would be a healthy
conversation around the issue of islam
is
islamism in the uk
and and in relation to terrorism because
i just feel like if you were to watch
the news
you wouldn't understand why anything is
happening that's the biggest problem
with with the media for me is it's lost
its explanatory power right if you watch
an event and then you watch the coverage
you wouldn't know why it's happening i
don't really think that i know
why someone would go into london bridge
near here and stab people to death right
i don't understand i don't know i think
most people in this country don't really
know right so and
and and when anything like that happens
we're always told well islam is a
religion of peace and most muslims are
peaceful there's no question about that
right but
but why why is that happening do you
sure i'm getting that like why is
someone doing that
yeah i mean i think that there's you
know for different terrorist attacks
there's different motivations
i think that
we have to be honest that you know
islamist extremism at the heart of it is
the construction of a global caliphate i
mean and then obviously british liberal
democratic values there's not much space
for british liberal democratic values
and that there will be various tactics
and strategies that will be deployed to
undermine those values uh in infiltrate
you know extremists would like to
infiltrate and influence the behavior of
public institutions
what goes on within those institutions
as well and i think ultimately
and another important point is that just
that sort of man-made legislation
there's not any place for that
under sort of you know islamist um
extremist mindsets so so these people
and we've had people want to talk about
the the the the battle between nation
states and the islamists absolutely in
in the middle east so so that's a really
interesting point to get into so i guess
what you're saying is what these people
want is to create a global caliphate and
they want to undermine the the liberal
democratic structures of our society
absolutely but how does some stabbing
someone on london bridge do that
well i think that
as i said in terms of the effectiveness
of it yeah you know that we could
definitely have a we could definitely
have a debate on that yeah i think that
but in terms of when i'm talking about
maybe almost a non-violent islamism you
can say
some people just say that you know the
best way to do this is would be to
intimidate non-muslims make them feel
fearful within their own country that
sort of intimidation factor make them
feel unsettled uncomfortable and aware
of our extremist presence a violent
terrorist attack can achieve that but
when i'm talking about you know
influencing behavior within public
institutions state schools would be
example it would almost be as you say
it's almost undermining those liberal
democratic structures and values
through taking control or rather
influencing behavior within public
institutions and i think that all too
often our sort of mainstream
political leaders
been sleeping at the wheel if i'm being
absolutely honest i think that when we
look at the labour party we've had
politicians such as
nad shah
who've talked about prevent
say that prevent alienates british
muslim people and then there was a poll
that showed that 56 percent of bishops
and people never heard of prevent
they're so alienated
and they're given that platform and
they're just spouting
you know very divisive
um messages about how people relate to
public institutions when in reality when
they if they were more optimistic and
i'm not saying that they should deny the
existence of anti-muslim prejudice
anti-muslim prejudice does exist in the
uk we should be we should be honest
about that especially in the labour
market when it comes to employment
private rented sector and you know when
it comes to housing there's issues there
as well
but to say you know prevent alienates
british muslims when more than half of
british muslims haven't heard or prevent
it does create that us and them kind of
mentality and then once someone is on
that path they can be very easily
exploited especially if they live in
communities which are very much mono
religious fairly segregated they don't
have experience of you know positive
relations outside of their own faith
group
and perhaps they're detached from
mainstream democracy those people are
quite easy to work on they're quite
susceptible or rather vulnerable to
extremist influences and once they're on
that path
then it can be a very slippery slope
islamist extremism so i think those are
the kind of processes at play when
you're talking about how islamist
extremism is a problem in britain
so
we've identified the problem
what's going to be the solution how do
we overcome this how do we have a more
cohesive society well i think that i
think equality i think it's about
ultimately building on what are sort of
classic british principles so i think
equality of opportunity would be one i
think that's something that people in
different ethnic and religious groups
can really buy into
most people don't interest in equality
of outcomes they expect fairness not
favors
uh i think that there's obviously a
discussion to be had in terms of
creating institutions where they're not
seen as the enemy or rather it's an
institution that's against me i think
that what we need to do we need to find
ways
to improve relations between citizen and
state i think that institut we need to
have institutional reforms where people
feel more connected to those
institutions i think all too often they
feel quite distant top down i think if
it's sort of leading officials in
different public institutions if they
just did more community work more
community engagement i think people they
just feel more of a closeness and i
think that provides a sense of
rootedness and belonging as well in
local communities if they feel that
they're the institutions in those
communities actually care about them or
they're interested in what they have to
say so i think those kind of things and
that can actually help to improve race
relations over time
as well i think we've also been talking
about islamist extremism i think one of
the finest things about british muslim
communities is how family oriented they
are i think there's strong forms of
intergenerational cohesion um within
british muslim communities well i feel
that one of the biggest problems in the
mainstream is for example
loneliness among the elderly and family
breakdown so
i think those are the kind of things
that maybe those kind of issues
surrounding family breakdown we should
talk about a little bit more yeah you
well you're absolutely right and we'll
we'll ask you our final question then
but i actually think that's so true
because the the some immigrant
communities do have those values the
british people used to have but
increasingly are starting to break down
there's erosion there yeah there is and
actually that is something we could kind
of share and learn from each other
absolutely it's not just about or what
you know ethnic minority communities can
learn from the white mainstream because
if you see for example in terms of
school performances it's pupils coming
from ethnic minded communities who are
performing particularly well even if
they're from deprived backgrounds the
thing it just is talking is basically we
need to have a discussion about what
really works
in britain and when we talk about those
shared values what we should be focusing
on i think we also have to focus what
the issues we have in britain which can
affect different communities it might
affect certain communities more
but also what's working well
in particular communities and how that
can help to
create a more it's almost like a
high-performing country as a whole you
know really boosting educational
outcomes across the board you know
enhancing levels of social stability how
we can say you know reduce criminal
activity i think just talking about how
we can create a more stable
society and a more demographic a more
democratically
healthy society i think those are the
discussions that we need to be happening
need to be having and that would be a
really mature way forward in terms of
our race relations conversation and more
generally how we can build stronger
levels of social cohesion
raheb thank you so much for coming on
the show if people want to find you
where is the place to do that well they
can follow me on twitter um uh
r-a-k-i-b-e-h-s-a-n
um and yeah i think to be honest if you
just start typing my first
name up
brilliant stuff thank you so much for
coming on the show
guys well we've got one more question
don't worry i will of course we've got
one more question uh which is what's the
one thing we're not talking about but we
really should be
i think it's something that i've touched
on a fair bit i think we need to talk
about family structure and the
importance of families in terms of you
know youth social development and i do
feel that you know when we talk more
generally about matters of equality
and inequality rather i think that the
impact of social in terms of family
breakdown and how that can impact or
rather how that can contribute towards
many social ills in local communities i
think that needs to be discussed a
little bit more in the social policy
space very good and the book of course
is manufactured grievance i really look
forward to reading it when can people
get it and where so you can pre-order
manufactured grievance on amazon and it
will be coming out in june 2022 so i'm
working hard on it at the moment
fantastic well thanks for coming on
we're going to do a couple of questions
for locals but in the meantime it's been
a great pleasure and thank you all for
watching and listening at home we will
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one
or a live stream and they all go out at
7 00 p.m uk time or 2 p.m eastern
standard take care and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below